today Kevin McCarthy removed me from the
house intelligence committee all for
doing my job for holding Trump
accountable and standing up to the
extreme Mega Republicans
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it is January 31st 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
if you have not joined us at
reubenreport.locals.com what are you
waiting for people we do a live post
game show after the live stream where I
answer questions take your comments you
can correct me you can belittle me
whatever you want because membership has
its privileges so please do join us if
you have not already I feel uh very very
good about today's show as a matter of
fact I have already pre-awarded Conor
and Phoenix with Shake Shack for lunch
because I feel so good about the show
that it seems like it's a double burger
day also Clyde is in studio today we'll
see if we can get him on camera at some
point we've got some guys downstairs
putting in some wood floors because we
have these cement floors downstairs and
as you guys know we have two babies now
and uh babies occasionally they're going
to fall they're going to whack their
head dead and apparently they shouldn't
do that on like seriously hard cement
floors so we're softening it up with a
little wood so you might hear a little
banging that's why I'm telling you fear
not it's not uh you know Gavin newsom's
thugs trying to break in here and bring
me back to California as far as we know
it's just people working on the floors
but as I said we do have a tremendous
show for you today we got a lot of Clips
we're a little all over the place I
think you're going to see the way we
weave this one is is going to be pretty
crafty if I do say so myself and what I
really want to talk about today
it's a little bit of a continuation of
the Elon stuff and the Free Speech stuff
but but not fully on that because I want
to talk about the shifting political
alliances because as I said yesterday
the thing that really uh lit Elon up
when we sat down was when we talked
about how I was a former Lefty and a
Democrat my whole life and then I had
this political Awakening and how I've
sort of shifted politically or seen the
light however you want to call it and
how that really has so mirrored his
political shift and I think that has
mirrored so many of your political
shifts and what I would say is is the
widest growing tent in American politics
today the disaffected liberal in which
way are they going to go and you guys
know they're always sort of like the
Bill Maher types who who kind of end up
still on the Democrat side but I think
there's a whole bunch of people who see
this new conservative thing this this
thing that I think DeSantis is doing so
well right here in Florida but it's
happening all over the country where
there can be a sort of new Republican
party a Republican party that shows some
teeth that shows some tolerance that
really is focused on individual rights
and all of those things and I want to
connect that and here's how we're going
to start the show today I want to
connect that to your personal sort of
political and existential philosophy
because I have come to the belief it
took me a long time to believe this
belief that you must believe in
something you have to believe in
something greater than the physical
world you must believe in something
greater than the thing that is happening
every single day because every single
day you open this little computer
machine in your pocket and there's just
a Litany of new craziness they want your
gas stoves today they want to put your
mask on tomorrow they want to inject you
with this stuff there's a war over there
it's just this never-ending thing and if
you only believe that is what is real
that is what is going on it's going to
drag you into the lunacy and I think
that is why over the last couple years
my good friend and mentor and guy we
play an awful lot of clips of uh Jordan
Peterson has exploded the way that he
has it's because he is talking about the
grand narratives whether they're
biblical Grand narratives or whether
it's just purely story sometimes fiction
stories like Pinocchio that you have to
believe in something
Beyond just this you just have to
otherwise you kind of go crazy or as
some might say you kind of lose the plot
and that brings us uh to Sam Harris I
want to talk about Sam Harris for a
moment and I do want to preface this by
saying I I was good friends with Sam
Harris for years he and his wife came
over to our house many many times for
dinner we went out to dinner many times
we used to hang out all of these things
people have asked me repeatedly to
comment on what's been going on with Sam
Harris because he seems to have gone off
the deep end well certainly related to
Trump over the last couple years and
then some covid stuff and he said some
crazy things about Hunter Biden and I've
barely touched on it and it just keeps
coming up so I'm gonna just do a little
something up top here to just address it
and then hopefully I can kind of let it
go because I don't sense that he's that
relevant anymore or sort of wants to be
that relevant in in a bizarre sense I
don't even mean that as a jab go go
mindfully meditate yourself like it's
all good uh but it's not just me that's
noticing this uh at the beginning of
Jordan's appearance on The Joe Rogan
Experience the other day uh they
mentioned the IDW and for those of you
that are a little late to the party the
IDW is the intellectual dark web it
basically was this ragtag group of
internet people and professors that all
were coming together about five years
ago to to fight the woke and most of it
took place a lot of it took place at Joe
Rogan Studio but most of it took place
in my garage at my house as I was
interviewing
Sam Harris and Jordan Peterson and the
Weinstein brothers and Ayan Hersey Ali
and Douglas Murray and Michael Sherman a
whole bunch more and this was like a
weird collection of political people Ben
Shapiro uh who didn't agree on a lot of
stuff but we kind of agreed that America
was good and fighting for Freedom was
good and things of that nature anyway
Sam has sort of gone off the deep end
with a lot of this uh and Joe and and
Jordan quickly hit on that at the top of
the podcast
yeah yeah yeah I still have hope for Sam
Harris yeah me too me too yeah I hope I
hope he makes a comeback
so I mean he's not really going away
he's just got some weird opinions yeah
well but there's there's plenty of that
floating around well you know I think
when you have like complex fascinating
brains they go off in all kinds of
different directions don't you think
this is this is one of the dangers of
being creative right most creative ideas
are wrong and a good section of those
wrong ones are fatal but now and then
you get one that's necessary
um
Peterson just cuts right to it doesn't
it um it's interesting because Joe says
you know he has a complex or fascinating
brain I I don't know that that's
actually the case about Sam like I don't
know and again I don't mean I really
don't mean any of this to be personal I
really hope you can that is coming
through the the machine right now
through those Airwaves and and those
internet Vibes
um but I don't think his thoughts were
that complex or fascinating I think he
chose to believe in purely the world
right here he that right he is like sort
of the number one atheist what was the
book uh the end of what was the book The
End Of not the end of religion
um what was the book The End of religion
the end of Faith thank you
um he wrote a book called the end of
Faith like he's written another book
waking up it was a guide to spirituality
without religion so he he wanted to
believe everything that was kind of up
here Joe is sort of saying well that
makes you sort of complex or fascinating
I actually think it's kind of the
reverse I think Jordan and they had
several debates about this Jordan seems
more complex to me Jordan seems more
fascinating to me and I think what's
happened here is when you only believe
in this thing and you're so you're only
responding to all the things happening
all day long you start having crazy
opinions because this world this mortal
world right here is pretty crazy uh so
Sam here's let's just go into a couple
of things that he he dropped the ball on
here
um one of them was he was wrong about an
awful lot of covid stuff related to
vaccines and lockdowns and a whole bunch
more he was on a podcast this is about
two weeks ago and just listen to the way
he's trying to back out of all of his
wrong opinions but people with far less
complex
and fascinating brains didn't get all
this stuff wrong and he did
had Cove had been worse
you know just enough worse to really get
our attention to really be undeniable
we would have had a different political
conversation around it there wouldn't
there wouldn't have been the same kind
of vaccine skepticism Brett Weinstein
would not have been
releasing
80 straight podcasts on the dangers of
the vaccine if a few variables were
changed I mean just just take it look
leave covet exactly as it is but just
make it preferentially dangerous
children rather than to old people right
just flip that around the the variable
of age if kids were dying by the
hundreds of thousands from from covid at
a rate of whatever it was you know one
percent say
um but it was pretty much all kids
we we would have had a very different
experience right and and that patience
that there would have been no
patience for vaccine skepticism right
and we everyone would have recognized
that this is not my body my choice this
is you're not going to kill my kids with
your with your ignorance right and you
change one other variable what if the
vaccines actually really did block
transmission
much better than they in fact did
right so look changing a lot of
variables okay yes if we go back and
think about everything differently than
reality played out I suppose you might
have been right about some of these
things but you were wrong about all of
these things why I'm not even sitting
here saying I'm the biggest most complex
intelligent person on the planet but I
wasn't wrong about all these things so
just quickly some of these things he
says had kovid been worse but it wasn't
and a lot of us knew from the beginning
go back to my videos by the time April
2020 was rolling around and they were
talking about a 99.9 something percent
survival rate and that it was only
really killing people that were 80 and
above and not that we should be
dismissive of people 80 and above with
those other comorbidities but it was
clear that locking us all down and
putting masks on that obviously weren't
going to work and then what ultimately
led to these vaccines and a whole bunch
more none of it really made sense so had
coven but been worse but it wasn't dude
that's one uh and then he says it really
would have got our attention did covet
not get our attention guys I you know
I'm a little out of it because you know
I'm busy during the day but were you
paying attention were people paying
attention to covid during Phoenix people
were was covered a thing for the last so
yeah people were paying attention to
covid uh then he he little jab at Brett
Weinstein which made no sense uh because
Brett was right about the dangers of the
vaccine uh and we're going to get to
more on that in just a little bit but uh
the heart issues uh all of these people
just dropping dead out of nowhere uh the
effect it's having on people's immune
systems the fact that right now more
people have died with the vaccine than
without the vaccine so just wrong wrong
wrong
and then this thing where he talks about
this flip on age had it been killing
kids it would have all been well but
again it wasn't
it wasn't and and
do you see how I'm linking this to if
you just are waking up every morning and
listening to what the experts are saying
listening to the what the machine is
saying not really having a narrative
that gives you pause to some of these
things right like understanding that
humans have been through it before and
been through it again and that there are
there are uh there are things there are
themes about human life that are way
bigger than just waking up and reading
what an expert says and trying to
respond to it and I think Sam
unfortunately got caught in that machine
but it wasn't just with kovid uh here he
is you may remember this one uh from a
couple months back uh getting really
some some crazy stuff out there related
to the hunter Biden laptop
at that point Hunter Biden literally
could have had the corpses of children
in his basement I would not have cared
now that's not that doesn't answer the
people who say is still completely
unfair
to not have looked at the laptop in a
timely way and to have shut down the you
know the New York post's twitter account
like that that's just a conspiracy
that's a left-wing conspiracy to deny
the presidency to Donald Trump
absolutely it was absolutely right but I
think it was warranted right and I'm and
again it's a coin toss as to whether or
not Sam I'm sorry that particular person
no but there's nothing conspiracy it's
not it was a conspiracy out in the open
it does but it doesn't matter if it was
it doesn't matter what parts conspiracy
what parts out in the open I mean I
think it's like if people get together
and talk and talk about what should we
do about this phenomenon you know if
it's like if there was an asteroid
hurtling toward Earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right is that a
conspiracy
yeah all right some of his metaphors I
don't even think quite make a lot of
sense now he doesn't care if Hunter
Biden had dead corpses that seems like
an issue now now maybe he was being a
little gratuitous when he said it but
you know if the son of the president the
crack smoking son of the president had a
couple dead bodies in the back do you
think they might be able to Blackmail
the president about that like it's not
nothing if the president's son has dead
bodies it's also not nothing if there's
tons of videos of the president's son
naked smoking crack that that's a
problem too not you know not to be so
old-fashioned over here
um so look everyone knew not everyone
I knew you probably knew many of the
people I associate now were screaming
about the hunter Biden laptop way back
when and even when we did not know it
was fully true we at least did not want
it to be censored and we certainly
didn't want the New York Post to be
censored and now we know it was all
coordinated we know through the Twitter
files the government was working on it
we know that those 50 former
intelligence officials some of whom work
at CNN right now that they all lied when
they said that the hunter Biden laptop
was misinformation so he got the covet
run wrong he got that one wrong and
again I'm not doing this to just blow
this guy apart I want to show you why
philosophy and and belief actually is is
deeply connected
to politics and getting things right I
want to mention one other thing as long
as we're talking about the hunter Biden
laptop story you guys may remember at
the beginning of the Trump presidency
I've never told this story I'm going to
tell this story one time I'm never going
to repeat it this is I'm but I was
sitting on this for a long time and then
we were reviewing the show this morning
I was like I better just tell this
freaking story remember at the beginning
of the Trump presidency when they when
it was Russia Russia Russia it was
Russia collusion and Russia stole the
election and Trump's a Russian agent
then they impeached him seven times and
all that stuff but literally year one of
the Trump presidency you may remember
for like four days the big story was
that Donald Trump Jr had lunch with some
sort of Russian for a half hour on the
Upper East Side do you remember that if
you don't remember you can Google it and
find out about it everyone said this is
the Smoking Gun he was getting
information from the Russians and and
this was the thing it was going to link
him to the father it was going to take
down the administration
I didn't think it was anything like
people have lunch with all sorts of
people and like I just wasn't buying any
of the nonsense anyway I got a phone
call from Sam Harris and he was quite
angry and I remember thinking this is
odd because he's the meditator he's the
Mr inner piece he was quite angry he
used the F-bomb a couple times about how
I was not being critical enough of trump
and I was enabling Trump and all of this
stuff and I said to him
I said Sam who do you want me to have on
the show I will have anyone you want on
the show to absolutely lay it to Trump
I've had you on the show going after
Trump I will gladly do it like I'm an
interviewer I'll have people who
disagree with me obviously he told me to
have David from on the show and I did
have David from on the show and I have
to say in retrospect probably my least
most uh impressive guest ever
um as a I just didn't buy really
anything he said but I did it I did it
in good faith to Sam
um anyway that's just a little bit of a
sidebar uh but one of the things that
then Sam really really got wrong was
that on January 9th 2021 uh he tweeted
this you may remember this
there's an important debate to have
about the wisdom of kicking Trump off
Twitter I still believe that it should
have happened years ago and that we've
paid a terrible price for the delay but
for the moment all I want to say is this
thanks Jack so he's thanking Jack Dorsey
Jack Dorsey of course is the disgraced
former head of Twitter who now we
absolutely know through the Twitter
files was running a company that Not
only was colluding with the government
to silence people but basically had all
left-wing activists doing all all sorts
of stuff and I know this firsthand from
Elon they still don't know exactly what
these people have done to the code so
Sam
again he was someone that was supposed
to be protecting Free Speech right as
this as this intellectual dark web crew
came together we were defending free
speech he wanted Trump to be banned
earlier than he was banned and then he
was applauding that basically a
technocrat was able to silence the
president of the United States uh this
is not good I don't think it's morally
consistent I don't think it's ethical or
anything else
anyway a couple days ago on another
podcast uh he went off on uh Elon Musk
and that was really why we eventually
decided to do uh the segment we're doing
right here we now have the spectacle of
Elon completely misusing his opportunity
to to live a fulfilling life oh God we
already we already talked about Trump
now we know we've got Elena now the word
elon's come out of your lips here's
another another friend who I have been
loath to talk about but right
um it's just like here's somebody who is
just the poster boy for having better
things to do and yet he's just tweeting
himself into a proper Fugue state
I just don't even know what to say about
that that is so disconnected from the
reality that I saw for two days for the
hours that I spent with Elon like the
guy is literally trying to put the train
back on the tracks relative for of
relative to our ability to speak freely
and communicate with each other and
everything else he's taking a deeply
broken system that is Twitter broken
because of its collusion with the
government broken because of its
internal problems and the misdirection
of guys like Jack Dorsey who Sam was
thanking and he's trying to make it an
even playing field again uh yes he has a
whole bunch of other things to do he's
trying to get us to Mars for one that
that seems like a full-time job but he's
stepping into this and as I said in the
Twitter thread he didn't need this
problem he didn't need it and also 44
billion dollars that he bought it for
even if you're the world's richest guy
buy anything for 44 billion that is
purging
probably hundreds of millions of dollars
a year is not necessarily the best
business situation he didn't do it for
fun I assure you although as I said he
was laughing a lot and kind of having
fun with people up there and sharing
memes with everybody and he showed us a
couple of funny videos and that sort of
thing he was genuinely as far as I could
tell unless I am unless he completely
had me Bamboozled unless Elon Musk
bought this thing just to punk everybody
and I don't think there's any evidence
of that he has brought all these people
back on Twitter he's clearly trying to
fix I mean it wasn't that I just talked
to him I talked to the programmers who
are getting the instructions from him
who are sitting there all day long
trying to fix this thing like what what
a what better fight is there than the
fight for free speech
I don't know I actually don't know uh so
yeah you kind of got that one wrong too
and Sam and Elon had gotten into it on
Twitter a whole bunch of times and I
just want to throw you one I thought
this was a fitting response that Elon
gave Sam on one of these Sam there is
such a thing as meditating too much and
I think that kind of gets to it I think
it kind of gets to uh that if you just
if it's just about meditation if it's
just about responding to the news if it
isn't about the lessons that people have
been
fighting for and telling stories about
way before us
you're going to get an awful lot of
things wrong and you're going to turn on
good people who are doing doing the
right thing Elon Musk is doing the right
thing right now I don't mean that as a
sycophant or a fanboy I mean it as a
professional who walked into a place of
business and saw people trying to fight
for all of what I consider to be the
right things so I hopefully won't even
have to address this again it's not fun
talking about a former friend I also
just let me just say one other thing as
it got a little tense with Sam and I
towards the end there I repeatedly and I
have all the text to prove it and I'm
never going to release private texts and
phone conversations
um I repeatedly said to him I don't care
about our political differences I
repeatedly said to him I might have a
blind spot on some of this stuff you
might have a blind spot on some of this
stuff he would never admit that he might
have a blind spot but I would always say
maybe I do which is why I had from on
years ago and I would always say that it
just it just simply also doesn't matter
like there are other reasons to be
friends outside of politics but but
perhaps if you don't believe in anything
if you don't believe in God but you
believe that Trump is the devil you
might start doing some weird stuff but
now here's what I want to do because I
don't want to make this all about Sam
and I don't want this to seem Petty or
shallow or anything else I want to talk
about how a mistaken philosophy a
confused philosophy and a philosophy
without belief Beyond again what goes on
right right in front of us all day long
is going to make people do crazy things
and one of the craziest people
I think really one of like the most
megalomichical megalomyacle just he's a
mega megalomaniac Jesus thank you
there's some water
Bill Gates he's a megalomaniac people
okay I don't like this guy uh I want to
show you a couple videos of him some of
them we're going to throw back to from a
while back and some will be current and
you'll see the trajectory that this guy
has been on for quite some time uh here
he is in March of 2021 equating wearing
masks to wearing pants you may note that
in the video we're about to show you
while the entire audience uh is going to
be masked we're not we cut that part out
but all the people he's sitting with are
not masked and he's holding his mask
while he's talking about the benefits of
masks March of 2021 so this is still
sort of middle of coveted stuff
what about masks I think there are a lot
of people in America who are confused
about whether they should be wearing a
mask and in the United Kingdom for
example they've scrapped that all
together well that's interesting you
know what is the downside of wearing a
mask I mean it's got to be tough you
know you have to wear pants uh I mean
this is tough stuff these societies are
so cruel why do they make you wear pants
I'm trying to figure it out
we're very glad you have yours on
um ah now okay so even the interviewer
there was like yeah you're not even
wearing your mask and they're all
sitting there without masks how he's as
he's talking about masks here's a
picture of a maskless Bill Gates with
other people have masks and you just
really need to understand this guys uh
Bill Gates who has more Farmland than
anyone in the United States who has
these houses that are worth hundreds of
millions of dollars he has this insane
compound uh in Washington you must
understand that at the height of Kobe
this guy was not wearing a mask around
his house but I assure you that all his
slaves his his indentured servants and
his workers were all wearing masks at
his house so that's what it's about
exercising power over people rather than
doing anything that has anything to do
with science or keeping people safe or
anything else now here's a video of Bill
Gates the fact that this guy keeps
getting on air this is what I kept
saying about fauci all along and these
people who get everything wrong wolensky
they keep showing up they get everything
wrong and they have no shame and I'm
Amazed by this concept I really I'm
Amazed by this concept like if I had
gotten everything wildly wrong
I don't mean political predictions I
mean the basic stuff
for all of these years well most likely
many of you would probably have tuned
out of the show Boy Dave gets a whole
bunch of stuff wrong and maybe I'm going
to watch something else that would make
a lot of sense and I'd probably think
about something else to do for a living
I wanted to be in the NBA I'd get going
on that okay but these people that get
everything wrong they still because
nobody ever pays the price because if
you're a leftist or a Democrat or a
globalist you have this privilege that
you can get everything wrong you can
wreck everything Gavin Newsom and they
will keep giving you more and more
credit more and more money more and more
power influence Etc so Gates just keeps
showing up in the media here he is uh
saying that kovid was naturally caused
something we do not know for a fact
actually most people that I trust seem
to believe this was leaked out of the
Wuhan lab and the NIH was doing gain of
function research there and now we know
that Pfizer was doing gain of function
research themselves but it's not just
that I want you to listen to the end of
this where he talks about epidemics in
the future and watch his mouth just
watch his mouth as he says that just
referenced intentional pandemics do you
Harbor any doubts about the origins of
covid-19 no the evidence is is very
clear that it's naturally caused
um you know it's a a bad virus and we're
going to have natural epidemics and
sadly we may have some unnatural
epidemics in the future
okay first off there isn't evidence that
it was naturally caused there isn't this
is still absolutely Up For Debate and
again most of the people that I trust
believe that this was leaked from the
Wuhan lab can we show it one more time
because why you can see the way his lips
sort of change he's sort of smiling as
he's saying that they're going to be
unnatural pandemics coming just
referenced intentional pandemics to you
um Harbor any doubts about the origins
of covid-19 no the evidence is is very
clear that it's naturally caused
um you know it's a bad virus and we're
going to have natural epidemics and
sadly we may have some unnatural
epidemics in the future
I'm telling you guys Bill Gates is evil
I don't know that he somehow had
anything to do with releasing this thing
but it seemed like he certainly is ready
to have something to do with releasing
the next one and speaking of that what
is the next thing that they are going to
unleash on you as they've been telling
you that they want to take your gas
stoves and they want you to drive
electric cars where you can whether you
can afford them or not well they do want
to lock you down because of climate and
Bill's going to make sure that you're
going to stay in your house he'll stay
in one of many many houses on an awful
lot of his land that he has but you you
stay in your basement
next pandemic as urgent now as the
threat from climate change
well they're very different you know
climate change just gets worse every
year as long as you continue emissions
uh a pandemic we're likely to go a fair
period of time without either a
naturally or intentionally cause
pandemic but when it does strike uh you
know we saw tens of millions of lives
and tens of trillions of dollars
fortunately the cost to be ready for the
next pandemic is a rounding error
compared to what it takes to re-tool the
modern economy
to solve climate change so uh you know
preparation for earthquakes pandemics
governments are responsible for their
people's welfare and and so a modest
investment should make us able to not
have a severe pandemic okay first off
again this thing where he smiles as he's
talking about the uh upcoming disasters
is really really bizarre right if you
feared the upcoming disasters be they
pandemics or earthquakes or climate
episodes or whatever maybe you wouldn't
be smiling about it if you were really
really worried about it that's number
one he also said that tens of millions
of lives were lost related to covid we
just checked 6.8 million people
worldwide that's actually shockingly low
if you think about it really think about
what the world has been like for the
last three years the things that hap
that we did all of the lunacy and 6.8
million people died not to dismiss any
of those deaths obviously
um but he seems to want you to think
that more people died because he needs
you to think that much like the climate
people need you to think that the world
is going to end in seven years AOC it's
all complete nonsense so the other thing
that Bill Gates is doing as you know he
is the this is just so wild the guy
created Microsoft
he created the Windows operating system
and then if you were to Flash Forward 30
years or 35 years whatever it is now he
is the largest Farmland owner in the
United States and you know what's really
really weird he's also been buying a
whole bunch of companies and making a
whole bunch of investments in companies
that make artificial meat now is that
weird I want to go on a little crazy
conspiracy adventure for you guys
um he's buying Farmland then he can do
whatever he wants with that so you can't
put cows on it or chickens on it or
whatever else and then he's buying these
companies and investing in things so
that you'll have to eat artificial meat
I'm going to have to really think about
this one videotape and you know I've
been pleased that the interest level
employment has gone up pretty
dramatically over the last two or three
years it was about 10 years ago I had
some professors come to me four or five
times a year they bring other experts
like learn okay how good are the models
what are the negative the facts what is
the uncertainty what are the positive
feedback cycles and so I've been on this
learning curve and that's the whole
reason I started this nuclear power
company called terracotta was not to
make money uh and I've avoided that uh
uh but although the artificial meat
companies I put money into I'm gonna
make more from those than I lost in the
other ones but
gosh darn it he's gonna make an awful
lot of money and artificial meat
companies while also ensuring that he
has all this land that we can't use for
grazing and raising meat and chicken and
all that stuff how bizarre but I do
wonder do you think he was eating meat
when he had his multiple dinners with
Jeffrey Epstein one of the issues that
stalked you is is that of your
relationship with Jeffrey Epstein do you
regret the relationship that you
maintained with him against Melinda's
advice and wishes I've said that I'm I
mean this is you're going way back in
time but yeah new audience I will say
for the you know over 100 times yeah I
shouldn't have had uh
dinners with him
um Epstein had a way of sexually
compromising people is that what Melinda
was warning you about
no
I mean it's
no I I had dinner with them uh and
that's all
and that you regret the relationship the
acquaintance that I had dinner with them
and and the relationship between the
foundation and Epstein which there never
was any relationship of any kind
okay you might note that he contradicts
himself well first off he does this
weird smiley thing again as it seems
like he's lying but at one point he says
dinner then he said dinners also it's
very unclear if there was a direct
relationship between Epstein and the
Gates Foundation you know Epstein was
funding all sorts of things that Gates
has his hands in whether it's the
Harvard endowment like all sorts of
crazy things
um but you know if you didn't do
anything with Epstein why do you regret
having dinner with the guy that's a
little kind of curious but the reason
I'm going off on Bill Gates right now is
because these people who again get
everything wrong and Sam Harris I would
put in the same bucket you get all of
these things wrong while while
denigrating the people who are standing
up for your individual rights and your
ability to live freely and everything
else fighting the globalists at every
front so you're getting the things wrong
and you're handicapping the people who
are doing the good work Bill Gates has
incredible influence over world leaders
this connects us to the whole world
economic Forum that we've done for the
last few weeks and much more Bill Gates
was asked recently
what would happen during a next pandemic
and he just wants us all to be more like
Australia
do you believe it's possible to prevent
the next pandemic
say again is it possible to prevent the
next pandemic yes if every country does
what Australia did
then you wouldn't be calling it a
pandemic uh
that's all
okay now I want to show you now I always
tell you these people get everything
wrong and they just keep marching
forward well here's a little video we
could have taken end the any endless
video of protests in Australia because
people were locked in their houses and
couldn't go to work and all the stuff
here's a quick 15 second video do you
think these people are thrilled with
Bill Gates oh if we could have just had
more of this and then exported it
throughout the world
foreign
[Music]
I honestly believe that Bill Gates
thinks those people are the problem
When You Believe in the collective When
You Believe in globalism When You
Believe in a top-down view of the world
that when you believe that you're God I
think he actually thinks he is a type of
God and when you believe that you don't
care that those people want to get out
there and see the sunshine and get out
there and play with the run around with
the Kangaroos and throw their boomerangs
and all the other things that
Australians do do they do what else
those are the two main things right
riding around on Kangaroos and throwing
boomerangs
you get the point uh he wants all
countries to be more like Australia well
you know what's going on in Australia
right now they are still still I saw
this video yesterday this is bananas
they are still pushing vaccines and
boosters and listen to the way that this
journalist on Australian TV frames it
listen to the way the guy is just this
is gross like get your barf bag ready go
well despite calls from Health
authorities to roll up house slaves for
a fifth dose a large amount of
Australians are still resisting getting
their covert booster shot according to
the latest data Eddie Meyer joins him
now to talk me through us um Eddie told
me through the numbers they're quite
surprising yeah it's quite interesting
this is research done for the Sydney
Morning Herald and the age and it
basically shows that there's a fall in
the number of us willing to go from
three to four doses and that's
particularly true in that more
vulnerable population over 65 just 24 of
them have um have had their fourth does
and right now overall just a third of us
have had our fourth dose wow so the
figures don't lie but why then are
people still reluctant to get another
booster when I had to check to some GPS
this morning and they say that there is
there's a lack of fear at the moment
people have seen themselves and others
get covered and they've been okay
they've had a couple of Doses and they
they seem to be complacent
all right guys close up your barf bag
put it aside let's just continue with
the show I mean there's so much there
there's a lack of fear they haven't
scared the average Australian enough to
get their fifth those the vaccines don't
work none of this works do you guys get
it yet it's literally going to be 2036
people are going to be on their 87th
vaccine and they're going to do a news
broadcast and they're going to go you
know people aren't interested in taking
their 88th vaccine and if you don't take
your 88th vaccine your fifth eyeball
might fall out right sure we all got
five eyeballs over the last couple years
we don't know why we've been injecting
ourselves in this weird stuff now you've
got four eyeballs that all kind of work
in sync with each other but you got this
one crazy eyeball and if you don't take
the 88
here's Justin Trudeau I hate this son of
a uh this is a while back but just
it's a good one relative to how the
media sort of Dances with all of the
people who are the evil people trying to
stick weird stuff into your body just
recently you and your wife got your shot
your first shot uh on her birthday of
all days uh did you feel a sense of
relief and joy you know it's amazing
because we were talking about how
important it was for everyone to get
vaccinated what a big deal it was to get
vaccinated so I thought that was all
built in already but getting that shot
really was an amazing feeling it it it
hits you did you cry
I I I cry it you know I cry at movies I
didn't cry at the at the shot but you
know it was a moment where where you
realize okay this is it and it wasn't so
much because I felt that I'm at high
risk because we're being careful and I'm
healthy and I'm young and although but
at the same time it's knowing that each
of us doing our part is getting through
this because we don't get through this
unless you know the vast majority of the
population gets that first shot and then
a few months later gets that second shot
that's how we get through it and it's
something that everyone can do and we're
just seeing Canadians come out in such
strong numbers all across the country to
say yeah yeah I want this covet thing to
end I want to get back to normal and the
way to do that is to make sure everyone
even that crusty Old Uncle who resists
or that friend who's skeptical encourage
them convince them tell them that they
need to get to get vaccinated because
this is how we get through it
you know I realized I just screwed all
you guys because you're all watching
this and I told you to use your barf bag
for the previous clip and now your barf
bags full you're watching Justin Trudeau
and I'm and there's nothing worse than
when you have to open a barf bag and
puke into the puke laid in barf bag so
you either overflowed your barf bag or
you puke this way
he is just I really hate that asexual
way of talking where everything I say I
say it like this though I can't be a bad
person because I'm talking like this
that I'm saying things and who would be
evil and also talk like this I'm Justin
Trudeau and I'm young and okay but I
just want your crusty Uncle to do what I
want him to do because I'm Justin
Trudeau and look at my hair I hate
whatever that thing is what do they call
that is they're afraid for that person
who just talks like this and you don't
have to know anything because you just
keep talking and people are looking at
you and you're just talking and smiling
and it's just great and it's wonderful
and you're just in Trudeau and sure your
dad was probably the Communist you all
know that oh my God I'm Justin Trudeau
but I want to show you guys how these
evil leaders be they people like Bill
Gates who have no right to have any
control over your life whatsoever
or Justin Trudeau who I would also argue
has no right to have any control over
your life but he is the prime minister
of a country they do have some Authority
I will accept that uh how they're bad
ideas are so easily shot down when
confronted with reality so this is an
Incredible video from yesterday this is
Scottish first Minister her name is
Nicola sturgeon and she is confronted
about the phrase trans women are women
relative to where trans women should go
to jail this one is a pure joy you will
not need your barf bag so wipe up your
mouth enjoy my question is are all trans
women women they haven't answered that
question well that's not the point that
we're dealing with yeah trans women are
women but in the present context there
is no automatic right for a trans woman
in our context where a trans woman is
not a woman no that is
that is circumstances in which a trans
woman will be housed in the
a woman born as a woman will be housed
in the real estate look we're talking
here about trans women I'm now asking
about women born as women I don't think
that our circumstances there but it's
different for trans women well yes and
I'm not so they're not equal that is not
that that is a risk assessment process
done for trans women that takes account
of the nature of the crime it clearly it
sets significant concern arises out of
sexual crime and whether it's
appropriate for them to be in a female
prison or a male prison
isn't it great when these people are
confronted with reality like good job by
that journalist and I always say it's
very refreshing when I can actually say
the word journalist and not use air
quotes trans women are not women they
are trans women and again if you are an
adult and you choose to live your life
as the opposite sex if you really
believe that is within you and you want
to put on a dress or have whatever
surgeries
I am and I don't understand I'm all for
it but but live go do your thing
go do your thing I have no right to tell
you how to live your life as a
autonomous functioning adult but when
you listen to these people so trans
women or women well okay should they be
in the women's prison oh well like I
wish well we've got well you can see and
they don't know what they're saying and
it's like uh okay well here's this trans
woman her name's Laura she's six foot
eight she just with her giant penis just
raped 18 girls
some of them under age we're gonna throw
him in the chicken
what do you think we're doing over here
so these people when confronted with
reality their ideas this is one of the
reasons they're always going for
censorship why why are the lefties and
the walksters always trying to censor
people well it's a powerful tool like
it's just it's just powerful in and of
itself but also if your ideas are really
bad the best way you could keep pushing
them out there is to silence all descent
and their ideas are terrible their ideas
you could poke through them easier than
poking through a wet paper bag that's
where we're at at the moment but there
are some leaders trying to do the right
thing so now let's bring this back to
the United States but the thing is when
you do the right thing you got to go all
the way you can't do half measures so
first I want to show you this is Utah
Governor Spencer Cox and he is now
banned gender affirming health care for
minors this part is good
it's happening in state houses all
across the country with Utah have you
heard about this now becoming the first
state to ban gender affirming care for
Trans minors this year that new law
keeps kids from getting gender affirming
surgeries while putting in indefinite
moratorium on things like puberty
blockers and hormone therapy
okay so this is very good now first off
I also I also want to mention that this
phrase gender affirming care it's not
affirming if you're chopping off your
boobs or your Wang that is disaffirming
that is
um not affirming okay affirming would be
like oh you have boobs you have a wang
we're going to see if we can get you
through this situation okay until you're
an adult and then you can make a
decision on your own but a 13 year old
walking in there or a nine-year-old
walking in there and saying I want drugs
because I don't want these body parts
that is not affirming their gender okay
that's just a fact I know you weirdos
not you watching this right now but you
weirdos who are watching this to try to
get me later I know you're going to go
crazy with this but it's just true it's
just true but the problem is that Utah
Governor Spencer who is a republican uh
Spencer Cox uh he gets it on at some
level right he just passed this gender
affirming care ban but here he is on a
zoom call all the about equity and
inclusion and yeah he's sharing his
pronouns okay
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon I am
Governor Spencer Cox and I have the
pleasure today of hosting the first one
Utah student town hall and uh my
preferred pronouns are he him and his
preferred pronouns are he him and his so
it's like this guy's gonna fail Utah
like there's just absolutely no doubt I
give you credit where you get credit he
also has that that Justin Trudeau thing
I'm Spencer Cox and my pronouns are he
him what is that it has nothing to do
with being gay by the way that's not a
gay thing or a straight thing or with
these like I don't know that Justin
Trudeau is gay he's probably been banged
a couple times it just seems like it
Newsom is definitely bang Trudeau
there's no uh don't Google that because
I'm sure it exists somewhere like some
weird CGI thing but but it's like I
don't think that's a gay thing I think
this this weird it's like like the
lizard person thing their their ideas
are so bad and then they're not even yet
all right so what happened uh what
happened that led us to a place where we
listen to experts let's say intellectual
experts uh like Sam Harris who get
everything wrong where we listen to
technology experts who then become
medical experts like Bill Gates
politicians like this Swedish woman and
the governor of oh and Justin Trudeau
all of these people who have none of
your interests in mind they have their
interests in mind how did we get there
and what do we do about it well at some
point you say enough is enough and you
find political leaders who are willing
to stand up for the right things cue
Florida we should just have should we
have like a gator come in when people
know I'm about to say something about
Florida and it's just so obvious and
just like a gator could just like slide
across the screen uh here is DeSantis
this is about a week and a half ago as
you know there was the big battle for
the RNC uh chairwoman slot it was Ronald
McDonald uh sorry Rana McDaniel versus
harmeet Dylan I had her meet Dylan on
the show she's an absolutely wonderful
first amendment lawyer uh and the base
really wanted her it was very weird
because Trump wanted McDaniel and she's
sort of the old one who's you know
really wrecked so much of what has
happened so much of the destruction in
the Carnage related to the Republicans
is definitely at her footsteps or at her
doorstep but Trump wanted her uh harmeet
would have been much better but here is
DeSantis this is before uh Rhonda
McDaniel won talking about how the
Republicans need change our meat would
be the right one so this is about a
governor doing the right thing trying to
find other people within the apparatus
to do the right thing as well well we've
had three substandard election Cycles in
a row 18 20 and 22 and I would say of
all three of those 22 was probably the
worst given the in the political
environment of a very unpopular
President Biden huge majorities of the
people think the country's going in the
wrong direction that is an environment
that's tailor-made to make big gains in
the house and the Senate and State House
State houses all across the country and
yet that didn't happen and in fact we
even lost ground in the U.S Senate and
so you know I think we need a change I
think we need to get some new blood in
the RNC why would you want to have your
headquarters in the most Democrat city
in America it's more Democrat than San
Francisco is so I think you get it in
real parts of the country you attract
people who want to want to live in those
parts of the country not DC insiders but
I do think we need some fresh thinking
and I here's the thing just just
practically speaking you need Grassroots
Republicans to power this organization
with volunteering and donations okay so
to be clear it did not go the way that
Governor DeSantis wanted it didn't go
the way I I wanted right I had harmine
on I would have had McDaniel on too I
think we reached out to her she's Mitt
Romney's niece by the way so there might
be some weird thing you could probably
extrapolate out of that
um but the base and again this is why
the whole thing was so weird the bass
was against McDaniel the bass was for
hermit and Trump was for McDaniel
something very weird is brewing there uh
but DeSantis I think had the right
position he did not get what he wants
that's one of those things where you
don't always get what you want but you
do have to set the example you have to
stand up for what's right and talk about
what's going on at the at the base level
at the Grassroots level and everything
else and then what happens when you do
that is that blueprint starts spreading
and one of the things I've been really
happy about I predicted it and it's so
far so good is that this new crop of
Republicans is coming in I think it
partly is because of the fight that they
had over the speaker leadership whether
McCarthy was going to get it or not and
they are showing some balls and that's
what they had to do uh here is Kevin
McCarthy the new house Speaker obviously
uh firing back at a leftist reporter who
was trying to get him over this George
Santos thing you know we haven't done
much on George Santos he's a republican
from Long Island Nassau County where I'm
from who it turns out that a lot of his
backstory was completely made up like
beyond beyond fictitious but oh my God a
politician lying I can't believe it and
McCarthy's just not falling for the Trap
no you know why I'm standing by him
because its constituents voted for I do
not have the power simply because if I
disagree with somebody or what they have
said that I remove them from elected
office now I will hold him to the same
standard I hold anyone else elected to
congress if for some way when we go
through ethics that he has broken the
law or you know then we will remove him
but it's not my role I believe in the
rule of law a person's innocent to
proven guilty and if I was to hold the
standard if somebody lied
Joe Biden couldn't be president right
now he told us we he had three degrees
he graduated first in his class the
numerous times before
yeah you know lying does not disqualify
you there would literally be nobody in
DC
I mean it would be a ghost it's a pretty
uh it's a pretty depressing ghost town
as is but it would there would be nobody
there if lying meant you could not be in
office now McCarthy's right you find out
that he he actually did something
illegal you got to deal with that but
lying is not the barometer and by the
way uh having or being let's say because
if you're a liar you're let's say at
some degree amoral something like that
uh if lying meant anything well ilhan
Omar married her brother we know that uh
Eric swalwell slept with the Chinese Spy
Who staffed his office we know that the
way you know those things aren't true is
they're never talk about on mainstream
media and if they were complete lies
mainstream media would destroy them very
easily so the the ignoring of stories is
now becoming a very easy barometer on
how to figure out whether something is
true or not so McCarthy of course is
doing the right thing and then not only
that well he also is removing Adam
Schiff and ilhan Omar and Eric swallow
from some of their committees they
should not be on committees these are
not good people or good Americans uh and
he really crushed a reporter who went
after him for doing just that you asked
me a question when I answer it it's the
answer to your question you don't get to
determine whether I answer your question
or not okay in all respect thank you no
no let's answer her question
you just raised the question I'm going
to be very clear with you the Intel
committee is different you know why
because what happens in the Intel
committee you don't know what happens in
the Intel committee although the secrets
are going on in the world
other members of Congress don't know
what did Adam Schiff do as the chairman
of the Intel committee what Adam Schiff
did use his power as a chairman and lie
to the American public even the
Inspector General said it when Devin
Nunes put out a memo he said it was
false when we had a laptop he used it
before an election to be politics and
say that it was false instead it was the
Russian but I will not be like Democrats
and play politics with Thief where they
removed Republicans from committees and
all committees so yes he can serve on a
committee but he will not serve on Intel
because it goes to the National Security
of America and I will always put them
first all right
so this is what we've been waiting for
from Republicans for quite some time
stand up for the right things play ball
play ball hard use some of the tools
that they're always using against you
guys and note the the clarity that he's
speaking with you know he's not Shifty
it's just here I we know that he was
lying Schiff we'll get to that in just a
second we know he was lying and these
are State secrets on the Intel committee
that someone like ilhan Omar should not
have that someone like swalwell should
not have that someone like shift should
not have and then you know what happened
believe it or not this past weekend on
CNN Dana Bash actually asked shift about
his lying let me give you another he
says that
um this is part of the of a pattern
ahead of the first Trump impeachment you
said the committee had not spoken to a
whistleblower in fact that turned out
not to be true you know the Washington
Post uh said so in their in their fact
check uh The Washington Post uh
identified that yes before the person
became a whistleblower they sought
advice from the committee uh when I was
asked the question I thought they
referred to whether we had brought the
Whistleblower in uh and I should have
been more clear in my answer
I mean it's such nonsense you get it we
don't have to get lost in the minutia of
who talked to who when and everything
else but Schiff is just a liar he should
not be on the Intel committee he's
running for Senator right he's a
congressman and now he's he's a
disgraced embarrassment think about it
the January 6 hearings nothing came of
it the impeachments nothing came again
these are the types of people that
should be ashamed of walking outside
after the grift that they have pulled on
the American people but they're
Democrats so they have Democrat
privilege you can lie about everything
you'll still get on CNN and they'll
treat you great let's contrast that to
what happens when you're a Republican
and you stand up for yourself and you
stand up for your party and most
importantly I would say you stand up for
your country well Jim Jordan who I
happen to like a lot congressman from
Ohio uh who I think is doing great work
and fighting big Tech and fighting for
free speech and a whole bunch more he
went on Chuck Todd's Sunday propaganda
show uh Meet the Press it he was a great
show when I was growing up about 30
years ago but it no longer is very sad
to say and here is Jim Jordan going off
on Chuck's height now note the way Chuck
Todd is asking these questions and you
tell me is Chuck Todd an impartial
Observer is he is he a journalist in his
manner or is he a Democrat activist take
a look
president president Trump had documents
locked in a room with Secret Service
protecting them President Biden had
documents in his garage and in a think
tank that was funded by the Chinese I
think there's a difference president
Trump was the only guy who was actually
president I mean you talk about that
you're worried about the Chinese and and
I'm just saying are you worried about
the Chinese and Donald they took
pictures they took pictures of are you
don't worry about that no I'm not but
they took pictures of of the documents
at Trump's house they took no pictures
of Dr Peck it's not just me who would
like to know what went on here Senator
Warner said it last week he would like
to get a briefing he went to see the
documents and guess what the FBI is
saying no but they took pictures
in Trump's home the issue is not whether
Joe but what Joe Biden did no the issue
the issue isn't under the law that's the
issue the issue of treatment do not seem
to ever see the same conspiratorial
problems when it's a republican those
were all investigated for four years and
they continued
does Chuck Todd seem like an impartial
Observer there trying to get to the
truth or does he seem like a lawyer for
the Democrats no matter what Jim Jordan
says about the difference between what's
going on here between the the Biden
docks and the Trump docks Chuck Todd is
fighting him on that do you think that
is how he treated Adam Schiff for all
the years that Adam Schiff was peddling
January 6 nonsense in Russia collusion
you know the answer I don't even have to
explain it to you now I want to show you
a 15 second video that I showed you
before because I want to show you how
all of these things once again are
connected the people who get everything
wrong they must be exposed as people who
get everything wrong we must stop paying
attention to them so let's go back to
that Bill Gates guy you'll see what I'm
doing here in just a second remember
what Bill Gates said about what we
should have done to have stopped kovid
you remember this from Mere 16 minutes
ago
do you believe it's possible to prevent
the next pandemic
say again is it possible to prevent the
next pandemic yes if every country does
what Australia did then you wouldn't be
calling it a pandemic uh
ah you remember that from 16 minutes ago
I know you guys don't have coveted brain
you remembered it now why am i showing
you that again because uh if every
country had done what Australia did well
last year during the Australian Open
Australia did not allow Novak Djokovic
into the country he is the number one
tennis player in the world he is not
faxed he is a young healthy person in
his 20s who's probably at the peak of
human Fitness as the number one tennis
player in the world they did not let him
in for the Australian Open last year you
know what happened this week
yeah he won the Australian Open and
there's Bill Gates in the audience
sitting there unmasked look at Bill
Gates face he's becoming Palpatine these
people become they all become Palpatine
you know it's he's yelling unlimited
power the Lightning's coming out of his
hands and his face is actually starting
to melt as you remember that's of course
what happened to Palpatine himself when
he was fighting with Mace Windu and yada
yada yada you get it okay so that's
pretty spectacular so Bill Gates you got
it wrong you wanted everybody to be like
Australia Australia lock down their
people they had protests they wouldn't
let the number one tennis player in a
year goes by number one tennis player
not vaxxed wins the uh Australian Open
pretty spectacular and what is really
spectacular about that is that uh
Djokovic actually represents the
individual he fought for his right to
his own bodily autonomy that's something
that leftists used to be into right they
were into this idea of my body my choice
he faced the adversity it is not fun for
a guy who is devoted his entire life to
something to say I will not go I'm not
going to be injected with this thing and
I will miss the Australian Open it's one
of the big ones it's one of the big ones
in tennis you don't want to miss that
but he did what was right and he has
been proven correct and you know what
that does it builds freaking character
Joe Rogan and Jordan Peterson there's a
thing that men need they need difficult
tasks and they need to know that they
can overcome difficult tasks and and
through that you develop your
your human potential you develop what
you're capable of doing and if you don't
encounter those things in life you you
remain feeble and you may fetal even
yeah and very uh not just immature but
um insecure well and not just insecure
but insecure then bitter yeah then
resents yes then dangerous yes
yeah that's right that's right you have
to face adversity just because the
machine says to you get injected just
because the machine says to you don't go
to Grandma's funeral and all the rest of
it you must do what is right for you and
that is the thing that they fear the
most
right I wish it wasn't this way I wish
it was a hell of a lot easier I suppose
I mean I think there's an actual Beauty
in this right like it might be the most
beautiful human thing there is so I'll
take away that wish I don't it's not
that I wish everything was easier
actually because the lesson here is the
purpose of the whole freaking thing
um but people are afraid people are
afraid and then what happens they get
you to do all these bad things and then
you just get everything wrong and as I
said earlier and I think this is the
case of Sam Harris you end up trying to
take out the very people who are
fighting for your ability to live freely
it is which is exactly what he's trying
to do with Elon Musk it's rather
extraordinary it's rather extraordinary
but let's take this from uh from the
individual level let's do this at a
macro level the societal level do you
know how you make a society flourish
well there are great people before us
who thought an awful lot about it you
might remember this little bite from my
last prageru video that we shot uh gosh
it's only about six months ago
the founders of America sought to create
a government whose primary purpose was
to protect the freedom of the individual
after that as far as George Ben and Tom
were concerned you were on your own
nobody saw this more clearly than the
19th century French writer Alexis de
tocqueville he came to America to see
what all the commotion was about and was
absolutely Blown Away
this new American democracy what he
called the equality of conditions was
not merely a new way to govern he
realized but a new way to live for de
tocqueville American individualism was
not about being self-centered but about
being self-reliant government can't
guarantee your happiness but it should
guarantee your right to pursue it this
is the only way to make progress on a
national level and still be
authentically inclusive because where
true Freedom exists there will be
individualism and where individualism
exists there will be true freedom
so it starts with you guys I know you
get it I know you get it but it starts
with you and if you can spread that we
can fix this thing why is it that the
best run Nations that often are just a
blip in history are where the individual
is the most important piece and it's a
bottom-up version and then of course yes
bad guys always come in and we're
dealing with a version of that in the
United States right now I think that's
what everyone's kind of feeling it's
like especially at the federal level
it's like man the collectivists are here
the Socialists you hear the Communists
are here the the One World Government
here the globalists are here the whole
thing it's here and we have to make a
choice in this moment do you just want
to be quiet about it and not do anything
do you want to go along with it do you
do you want when Bill Gates tells you to
be locked down because of climate do you
want to go along with it or while you
have emoticon of Freedom left do you
want to jump in and and get in the fight
I think it's fairly obvious because what
you want is a society that allows choice
and a society that allows choice will
always be a healthy society and it will
give you a winning strategy but don't
listen to me how about Thomas soul what
would you do to help those blacks who
are still in a very low economic
condition
in terms of education for example well
that's uh very easy I would allow their
parents to have a choice of where to
send them to school whether that choice
is called a voucher scheme open
enrollment tuition tax credit any kind
of scheme of that soil that would put
that power in the hands of their parents
mainly because that would mean that the
schools would have to be responsive to
them as it is now the school is a
monopoly as blacks emerged from slavery
oh and minute percentage could read or
write and yet in half a century over
half the black population was literate
an economic historians call that one of
the most remarkable things in history
and yet the census of 1850 showed that
most free blacks could read and write so
I don't think that the fact that people
have little education means that they
are in any way uh poor judges
than distant bureaucrats who have their
own access to grind and run the public
school system
get it stop exporting your decisions to
as what Thomas Seoul calls distant
bureaucrats these people who don't care
about you and they don't deserve your
attention they don't deserve your tax
dollars they really don't deserve your
respect or anything else they are they
are sucking you off but not in the good
way
and on that note we've got a post game
show coming up in just a moment you can
join us at reubenreport.locals.com just
a reminder guys we are completely
independent we are completely
independent I know that there has been a
big brouhaha lately you know the uh the
fight between daily wire and Crowder and
there's plays and all of these different
things I decided as of January 1st this
year we were going to do this completely
independently through Rumble and locals
meaning it's us it's us so if you'd like
to join us on this adventure you can
toss in a couple bucks a month at
reubenreport.locals.com you get ad-free
stuff you get early videos you get the
live post game shows and a whole bunch
more uh part one of my interview with
Michael malis is up right now on YouTube
and Rumble the full thing is up on
locals right now because you get stuff
early we leave you with Joe and Jill
Biden and I'll see you guys in 37
seconds
come on up Joe
no you're not going to dance believe me
we don't want to ruin the evening
[Music]